[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la grande guerre années après années
la révolution industrielle avait débuté
dans les toutes dernières années du
xviiie siècle en grande-bretagne la
france suivi ce mouvement au début du
19e siècle et l'allemagne à partir de
l'accélération de la production
conduisit cpi à rechercher de nouveaux
marchés à l'étranger le continent
africain se situer sur la route de ces
développements économiques
le nationalisme l'impérialisme et le
militarisme entraînèrent une quinzaine
d'années d'affrontements coloniaux entre
les trois grandes puissances européennes
une fois de plus elle se retrouvèrent à
l'aube d'une nouvelle guerre
[Musique]
certains chefs de gouvernement enterre
de promouvoir la paix lors de congrès
internationaux comme le tsar nicolas ii
de russie qui en 1899 rassembla les
délégations de 36 gouvernements à la
haye dans le but de trouver le moyen
d'apaiser les tensions et de limiter la
course à l'armement
[Musique]
cette convention fut un échec mais au
moins une cour internationale de justice
fut instaurée elle fonctionne encore de
nos jours
en 1914 le réseau des alliances et des
rivalités internationales plongent à
l'europe dont le désastre d'une guerre
qui ravage à de nombreux pays les
combats se déroulaient sur terre sur mer
ou dans les airs elle se termina pour
laisser la place à une période surnommée
la paix armée
le résultat fut la disparition de quatre
empire et la mort de plus de 15 millions
de soldats et de civils
il en ressortit un nouvel ordre mondial
qui concernait une population immense
mais d'ores et déjà en europe
centre culturel du monde / les
ressentiments politiques et les haines
raciales un second conflit semblait
inévitable dans un avenir proche
[Musique]
pourquoi la guerre
en 1914 pour de nombreuses raisons
on pouvait croire l'europe unifiée les
structures sociales et culturelles
étaient similaires et les diverses
monarchies étaient liées entre elles par
le sang ou les mariages
[Musique]
en allemagne le kaiser guillaume ii
était le neveu du roi edouard vii de
grande bretagne est le cousin du tsar
russe nicolas ces aristocrates
exerçaient des charges honorifique dans
leurs armées respectives
ceux qui pouvaient exalté leurs
penchants militariste
[Musique]
d'un autre côté la guerre des balkans en
1912 et 1913 avait vu la serbie
conquérir les territoires turcs est
envisagé de se rendre maîtres d'autres
terres au nord de l'adriatique encore
sous la houlette de l' empire
austro-hongrois
cette question opposait donc la serbie à
l' empire austro-hongrois la plus faible
des puissances continentales
parallèlement les perdants de ce conflit
l'empiré ottoman et la bulgarie ne
rêvait que de revanche
en allemagne le couronnement du nouvel
empereur guillaume 2 avait entraîné la
chute du chancelier bismarck et un
changement de direction brutal de la
politique étrangère du gouvernement
de plus l'émergence rapide d'une
allemagne unifiée au coeur des nations
industrialisées et est une source
d'inquiétude pour nombre d'entre elles
[Musique]
la france en particulier apparaissait
particulièrement revancharde
le ressentiment envers l'allemagne et
est immense après l'humiliante défaite
contre la prusse en 1870 et la perte de
la lorraine et de l'alsace qui en fut la
conséquence
[Musique]
le grand allié de la france la russie
voyait aussi dans l'émergence allemand
une menace pour sa domination sur
l'europe centrale et de l'est
[Musique]
de son côté la grande-bretagne tâche est
de rester à distance des querelles de
ses voisins elle était considérée comme
la plus grande puissance coloniale et se
sentait à l'abri grâce à son empire et
au commonwealth l'émergence du
militarisme allemand était observée avec
la plus grande attention et londres
s'inquiétait des pertes territoriale de
son allié ottoman au cours du conflit
dans les balkans
guillaume 2 ne faisait pas mystère de sa
volonté de faire de l'allemagne une
nation influente parmi les nations et
d'employer la force militaire pour faire
aboutir ses ambitions
[Musique]
l'allemagne avait des possessions
accessible seulement par voie maritime
et le kaiser était profondément jaloux
de la royal navy britannique
il décida de créer une flotte qui
pourrait égaler la flotte anglaise
pour y parvenir il trouva un appui
enthousiaste en la personne de l'amiral
phone pire pitts qui fit son possible
pour concrétiser le rêve de son kaiser
dès que celui ci eut augmenté
considérablement le budget alloué à son
armée
[Musique]
c'est fait grandir les britanniques
méfiant assez pour lancer en 1905 le
cuirassé hms dhr et neuf construit et
mis à l'eau en quatre mois
cette nouvelle norme était un bond
technologique immense pour la royal navy
et lui offrait une nette supériorité sur
ses rivales
mais son coût de 3 millions de livres
avait mis le gouvernement de sa majesté
en difficulté son lancement est une
incitation à la course à l'armement
car toutes les marines du monde
comprirent que le cuirassé et l avenir
de la puissance navale
[Musique]
il était aussi évident que les
britanniques avaient la volonté de
maintenir leur suprématie en mer alors
que les allemands ne ménageaient pas
leurs efforts pour les égaler
[Musique]
en 1913 lorsque la marine britannique
lance à un autre type de cuirassés le
type queen elizabeth
la surprise fut immense ce navire
emporté des canons de 15 pouces soit 380
mm
les plus gros du monde et qui bien sûr
avait une très longue portée
ce nouveau cuir assez rapide parce qu'il
était le premier à être équipé de
moteurs diesel renforça la course à
l'armement des autres pays car leur
marine réclamer à leur tour des
cuirassés comparables
les tensions étaient à leur paroxysme en
europe exacerbée par la certitude que
les futurs belligérants considéré comme
tel avait depuis longtemps établi des
plans de guerre pour ne rien laisser à
la chance et au hasard
comprenant des déplacements de troupes
précis et un inventaire de cibles
soigneusement choisis
les moyens de transport notamment le
rail et la route étaient les axes
principaux de progression de ses plans
lors de la guerre de 1870 les prussiens
et est resté efficacement proche des
voies ferrées et les utilisaient pour
déplacer rapidement leurs troupes
là où elle était nécessaire alors que
les trains français restées coincées
dans les gares
faute d'infrastructures
le traité militaire de 1893 entre la
france et la russie avait fortement
inquiété le chef d'état major de
l'époque le comte von schlieffen
supputons le danger potentiel pour
l'allemagne de devoir faire la guerre
sur deux fronts à l'est et à l'ouest
il imagina un plan qui fut dévoilée en
ce plan détaille est minutieusement
comment mobiliser un million d'hommes
pour écraser la france en 42 jours
ensuite il devenait possible de se
tourner vers l'est pour défaire les
russes il était certain que la russie
mettrait plus de temps à se mettre en
mouvement en raison de sa très grande
superficie
l'élément clé pour le succès de ce plan
était un as au combiné depuis l'est de
la france pendant que le gros des forces
traverserait la belgique et le
luxembourg pour arriver au nord-est de
paris
la neutralité de la belgique était
supposé garantie par un traité signé en
1839 entre la grande bretagne et
l'allemagne entre autres au cours des
années précédant la guerre le successeur
de schlieffen le général helmut von
moltke modifia le plan original du
compte
ce dernier était si hanté par son plan
qu'avant de mourir ses derniers mots
furent ne pas oublier de renforcer le
flanc droit
l'information de l'existence du plan
schlieffen obligea les français à se
lancer frénétiquement dans des projets
de planification le plan le plus
important fut le 17e qui avait comme
objectif prioritaire de récupérer
l'alsace et la lorraine
en raison de leur politique de
recrutement
la france et l'allemagne deux grands
pays européens avaient deux grandes
armées
l'emploi de ces armes et pour la
conquête de colonies et l'existence de
plans de guerre secrète ne firent
qu'accentuer les tensions et les
frictions
lorsque la mobilisation générale fut
décrétée dans ces pays plus de trois
millions d'hommes furent appelés sous
les drapeaux
les militaires et les politiciens tout
comme le public pensait généralement une
fois mise en marche
l'armée était une machine on ne pouvait
plus stopper
l'ordre de mobilisation était considérée
comme une déclaration de guerre et non
pas comme un simple préliminaire
[Musique]
tant de ressentiment était accumulée de
part et d'autre que ce n'était qu'une
question de temps pour qu'un événement
viennent mettre le feu aux poudres 1 et
plonger l'europe dans la guerre des deux
côtés on était certain que cette guerre
ne durerait que quelques semaines
quelques mois au tout au plus personne
ne pouvait imaginer les cinq années
d'affrontement et de destruction qui
allait suivre
l'étincelle eu lieu le 28 juin 1914
l'héritier de l'empiré austro-hongrois
l'archiduc franz ferdinand et son épouse
sofia était en visite officielle à
sarajevo la capitale de la bosnie un
jeune étudiant seube gabrilo prinzip 19
ans membre d'un groupe nationaliste
serbo-bosniaque appelé la main noire
ville à l'occasion d'attirer l'attention
sur leur cause nationaliste
[Applaudissements]
lorsque la voiture du couple impérial
passa devant lui le jeune gabrilo leva
son pistolet et tire à 2 fois tuant
franz ferdinand et sa femme
[Musique]
si l'autriche avait immédiatement réagi
il est probable que le reste de l'europe
n'aurait pas bougé mais la réaction
hésitante de l'autriche n'arriva que
quatre semaines plus tard le 23 juillet
après plusieurs réunions avec le kaiser
guillaume 2
elle prit la forme d'un ultimatum
comportant dix conditions dans huit
furent immédiatement acceptée par les
serbes
sous la pression de la russie et de la
grande bretagne tout en menaçant de
soumettre les deux autres au tribunal
international de la haye
l'autriche annonça le 25 juillet que la
réponse serbe n'était pas satisfaisante
et déclara la guerre le 28
[Musique]
la réponse russe du tsar nicolas ii et
de son ministre de la guerre le
grand-duc nicolas fut de mobiliser
l'armée pour venir en aide à leurs
alliés serre
les allemands avaient signé avec
l'italie et l'autriche
le traité de la triple alliance il
assurait les autrichiens de leur soutien
et commencèrent leur mobilisation
ils exigèrent de la france et de leurs
alliés britanniques qu'ils restent
neutres et qu'ils tentent de stopper les
préparatifs russes
comme signe de bonne volonté ils
proposèrent aux français les
places-fortes frontalière qu'il
revendiquait
la france refuse à et proclama la
mobilisation générale dans les dernières
heures du 31 juillet le dimanche 2 août
les troupes allemandes entre air au
luxembourg
le matin du lundi 3 août les allemands
déclaré la guerre à la france
au même moment les belges refusé
d'accéder à la demande des allemands de
traverser leur pays en grande bretagne
c'était les vacances
les anglais étaient nombreux à être
partis sans se soucier du désastre à
venir
il ne le découvrir qu'en lisant les
ordres de mobilisation
le mardi 4 août l'armée allemande
déclara la guerre à la belgique et le
plan schlieffen fut mise en action
l'invasion de ce pays des buts à
[Musique]
la grande bretagne alliés de la belgique
ordonna une reddition général aux
allemands mais le chancelier batman
holweg l'ignora prétextant que le traité
anglo belge n'était qu'un simple bout de
papier
à 23h le gouvernement britannique
déclara la guerre à l'allemagne
le même jour le gouvernement des
états-unis se déclare à neutre
[Musique]
la france mobilise à plus d'un million
700 mille hommes qui furent affectés à
cinq armées est envoyé vers la frontière
nord-est
[Applaudissements]
l'allemagne envoya un million cinq cent
mille hommes sur la frontière entre la
belgique et la france et donna l'ordre
aux croiseurs gay bonne et brest flow
d'attaquer lé port de l'algérie
française
deux cent mille hommes furent envoyés en
prusse orientale en prévision d'une
offensive russe
les russes n'avaient pas attendu pour
mobiliser leurs troupes et ils
marchèrent sur la prusse avec deux armes
et de 300 mille hommes chacune
leur armée et en plus petit les
britanniques ne mirent pas longtemps à
organiser et à envoyer en france
leurs corps expéditionnaire de bataillon
est une division de cavalerie qui se
montait à 150 mille hommes ils
arrivèrent en france le 7 août et
marcheurs sur la belgique pour prendre
leurs positions autour de mons
[Musique]
les opérations militaires des bus ter
sur trois fronts le front ouest où
franco belge
le front sud ou france herbe et le front
est
ou front russe
[Musique]
migros
la stratégie allemande reposant sur une
rapide défaite française grâce à la
guerre éclair du plan schlieffen fut
gravement ralenti en raison d'une forte
résistance à liège namur et surtout à
anvers de la part de la petite armée
belge forte de seulement 250 mille
hommes
les allemands les avait surnommé
ironiquement les soldats de chocolat
[Applaudissements]
les soldats du kaiser furent forcés
d'utiliser l'artillerie lourde et en
particulier les nouveaux très gros
mortier pour écraser les forteresses
belge il subir de lourdes pertes
handicapant le flanc droit de leur
offensive dans les semaines qui
suivirent
[Musique]
la plus importante campagne de la guerre
commença avec les batailles sur la
frontière du front ouest
le 8 août 1914
selon le 17e plan de joseph joffre les
français lance r5 offensive
la première avait pour objectif la ville
de mulhouse en alsace et était conduite
par le général pol pot
les combats le long de la frontière
franco-belge durèrent dix jours et 30000
soldats français y laissèrent la vie
les batailles de mulhouse de lorraine
des ardennes de charleroi et de manse
commencèrent pratiquement simultanément
ce fut l'affrontement direct entre le
xviie plan du général joffre et le plan
du compte je lis fun
les français marc cher pour leurs
premiers assauts couleurs levé musique
et baïonnette au canon
[Applaudissements]
les premiers combats pour mulhouse et la
lorraine furent des succès mais la
tactique allemande était d'entraîner
l'infanterie française dans des
embuscades où elle pouvait être anéantie
par des mitrailleuses et des tirs
d'artillerie
[Musique]
les allemands réussir alors leurs contre
attaques et les français furent
repoussées jusqu'à leur position de
départ
[Musique]
les unités de reconnaissance française
très innovante découvrir la stratégie
allemande
si bien que le haut commandement pu se
préparer pour mettre en place une
défense efficace
pendant ce temps les allemands lancèrent
une contre attaque en lorraine et dans
les ardennes c'est une zone forestière
impraticable qui s'étend des deux côtés
de la frontière au nord de m
deux armées françaises marchèrent sur la
belgique pour foncer sur les allemands
qui étaient en train de traverser le
luxembourg et le sud est de la belgique
dans les batailles qui suivirent les
français en sous-nombre subir des pertes
sévères
la troisième armée du général ruffey et
la quatrième armée du général fernand de
l'angle furent pratiquement balayé ils
furent forcés de battre en retraite
jusqu'à leur position entre la meuse et
la marne
leur flanc droit s'appuyant à la
forteresse de verdun
[Musique]
le 12 août 1914 deux cent mille soldats
austro-hongrois dirigée par le général
pq rec envahir la serbie déclenchant la
bataille de la rivière jadart les
soldats serbes sous le commandement du
maréchal tout nique les forces air à se
retirer
[Musique]
le 16 août un peintre médiocre né en
autriche
adolf hitler se porta volontaire pour
combattre avec l'armée allemande où il
fut affecté comme estafette il y fut
décoré à plusieurs reprises
[Musique]
le 23 août le gouvernement japonais
déclara la guerre à l'allemagne et à l'
empire austro-hongrois et lança une
attaque contre tingmao une colonie
allemande en chine
[Musique]
lors de la troisième confrontation de la
bataille des frontières à charleroi les
allemands remportèrent leur première
victoire indiscutable sur la 5ème armée
du général la rosa le général lanrezac
avaient anticipé que les allemands
allaient se retrancher en belgique mais
son supérieur le général joffre lui
donna l'ordre de prendre position entre
les rivière sambre et meuse afin de
stopper la principale avancée allemands
alors que l'affrontement était en cours
les allemands pilonnèrent la ville et la
garnison de namur et la cité tomba le 25
août 1914
[Musique]
lonza qu'espérer que les force
expéditionnaire britannique arriverait
rapidement à prendre leurs positions
pour le soutenir
mais les allemands furent plus rapide et
s'emparèrent de deux ponts sur la cendre
une action qui bloqua les troupes
françaises
[Musique]
après deux jours d'âpres combats les
français avaient enregistré des pertes
sévères à l'ouest de leur lignée celle
ci commencèrent à céder mettant en
danger le flanc droit britannique poster
annonce qu'il subissait déjà de dures
attaques de la part de la première armée
du général von cloud
[Applaudissements]
lanrezac et les restes de sa 5ème armée
furent forcés de reculer ce qui sera
probablement cette armée française d'une
destruction totale
arguant de cette défaite humiliante le
général joffre fille de l'anrac son bouc
émissaire pour toutes les erreurs
françaises y compris de celle de son
propre 17e plan
les britanniques avaient déployé deux
corps d'infanterie à une vingtaine de
kilomètres à l'est et à l'ouest deux
manches face au canal leurs pointes est
pratiquement au contact de la 5ème armée
en train de reculer
les allemands espérait aussi briser les
lignes de la task force britannique sous
le commandement de seurre john french
les anglais utilisé le fusil lee enfield
capable de tirer avec précision jusqu'à
15 coups par minute les allemands
tombèrent par milliers en réalité nombre
d'entre eux étaient persuadés que
l'adversaire disposait de mitrailleuses
temps s'étire été rapide et précis les
pertes britanniques furent également
sérieuse et soeurs john french donna
l'ordre de retrait à la minute où il a
pris ce qui était arrivé à l'armée de
l'anrac rendant la fusion des deux
forces désormais impossible confrontés à
leur propre perte et aux blessures de
certains chefs les allemands prirent la
décision de ne pas les poursuivre
après cette défaite les britanniques et
les français reculent airs jusqu'aux
environs de paris
face à cette situation von moltke chef
d'état-major allemand derroja au plan
schlieffen et donna l'ordre à ses
troupes au nord-est de marcher vers la
capitale française
le 26 août cette manoeuvre força le
second corps britanniques sous le
commandement du général à smith de rien
à la tête de quarante mille hommes
épuisés à combattre les troupes
allemandes et près de le cateau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la capacité de tir de l'infanterie
britannique se montre à nouveau à son
avantage et l'avancée allemande de fûts
ralenti assez de temps pour que les
alliés se réorganise et arrive à envoyer
la 5ème armée française du général louis
franchet soulager la pression subie par
les britanniques en attaquant puis en
stoppant quelques temps les troupes du
général von bülow
le 28 août 1914 les forces navales
britanniques coulèrent trois croiseurs
allemands près d'heligoland une île de
la mer du nord
[Musique]
au cours de cette action les
britanniques se trouvaient eux mêmes en
danger car en sous-nombre face aux
navires allemands ils réussir à s'en
tirer seulement grâce aux navires de
l'amiral dévide betty qui était en train
d'approcher à une quarantaine de milles
nautiques au nord
les allemands perdirent 1200 marins
contre seulement 35 pour les
britanniques
conséquence de cette opération betty
avait renforcé sa réputation de grand
stratège navale
[Musique]
à l'est de la marde entre paris et
verdun les troupes françaises et
britanniques
épuisée lancèrent une nouvelle contre
attaque l'action clé de l'offensive de
la marne
la bataille de l'ourcq füle attaque par
la sixième armée française du général
joseph galliéni gouverneur militaire de
paris contre le flanc droit
laissé sans protection de la première
armée du général von gluck à l'est de
paris le 6 septembre 1914
le flanc droit allemand mal défendu
l'esa une brèche d'une trentaine de
kilomètres dont les alliés profitèrent
rapidement vente clouque était persuadé
que cette attaque française n'était
qu'une manoeuvre de diversion et n'en
voyait pas beaucoup de renforts
préférant continuer à marcher avec ses
soldats vers le sud
chassant les restes des troupes
expéditionnaire britannique le 7
septembre
il réalisa son erreur et donna l'ordre à
ses troupes de faire demi tour et de
franchir la marne pour se diriger vers
l'ouest afin d'engager la 7e armée
française du général michel maunoury
surpris par l'attaqué allemande
maunoury manquer totalement de renforts
le maréchal joffre fille partir de paris
vers le front 6000 soldats de réserve
dans 600 taxis les célèbres taxis de
l'ama j'offre fut l'artisan principal de
la victoire décisive de la marque
pendant ce temps les troupes
britanniques s'engouffrait dans la
brèche et virèrent vers l'est pour se
lancer à l'attaqué du flanc droit de la
deuxième armée allemande dans ce qui est
désormais connu comme la bataille des
deux morin
le 8 septembre la brèche fut élargie par
une attaque surprise de la 5ème armée de
ferdinand foch entre la deuxième armée
allemande de von bülow
[Musique]
les attaques et les contre attaques dans
la région de la marne conduite par un
camp ou l'autre se succédèrent pendant
trois jours les affrontements les plus
sanglants eurent lieu à
vitry-le-françois la forêt de l'argonne
fut atteinte par les offensives lancées
en alsace et en lorraine au sud-est de
verdun craignant la possibilité d'une
offensive britannique majeure sur son
flanc le plus faible
le chef du haut commandement allemand
helmut von moltke donna l'ordre at look
de reculer ses troupes jusqu'à une ligne
entre noyon et verdun le long de l'oise
le retrait allemand signé à la fin de la
bataille de la marne
ces six faces furent un succès
stratégique pour les français et les
britanniques
elle avait permis de repousser
l'offensive allemande et de reprendre un
peu du terrain perdu les semaines
précédentes
[Musique]
les espoirs allemands de parvenir à
mettre un terme à la guerre rapidement
sur le front ouest ainsi que l'espagne
est le plan schlieffen était annihilée
leur pire cauchemar la guerre sur deux
fronts et est devenu une réalité
[Musique]
dès lors les grands mouvements de
troupes étaient terminées les deux
comprirent position dans d'innombrables
tranché
[Musique]
ces combats avaient coûté cher aux deux
armées les français avaient perdu 250
mille hommes les britanniques 13000 les
allemands de 120 milles
[Musique]
sur le front est deux armées russes
attaquèrent la prusse orientale au début
du mois d'août 1914
la deuxième armée du général alexander
serov progressait depuis le sud est et
la première armée du général pas veulent
renkens faisait de même depuis le
nord-est
le plan russe consistait à lancer la
première armée contre la viiie armée
allemande du général max von fritz vite
pour un assaut frontal tandis que
l'armée de samsonov encercleraient les
allemands en dépit des longues distances
et du terrain difficile de la région des
lacs de mazurie
[Musique]
l'opération commence à convenablement
merengue ont testé samsonov et leur
vendetta personnelle fini par aboutir à
une désastreuse défaite pour les russes
as tu as loupé onen où ils perdirent
3000 hommes
le 20 août le général max von prix de
witte fut relevé de ses fonctions et
remplacé par le général paul von
hindenburg on affecta à la tête de son
état major le prêt à gré cif erik lund
or l'homme qui s'était emparée de liège
en belgique
les allemands connaissait la rivalité
entre les deux commandants russe après
avoir intercepté un message radio envoyé
aux deux armées il avait une idée
précise de tous leurs plans
alors là où franck n'a au sud de la
prusse les deux armées étaient engagés
dans une bataille furieuse permettant
aux allemands de concentrer leurs
troupes près de la ville de tannenberg
pour organiser une embuscade contre
102,9 qui ne s'y attendait pas le 29
août les allemands encerclèrent la
deuxième armée de samsonov sur trois
côtés et l'année en pire en faisant 95
mille prisonniers et tuant plus de 30000
soldats russes
[Musique]
ceci a mené les alliés a abandonné
l'idée d'une invasion de la prusse
orientale et fit naître de sérieux
doutes en france et en angleterre
à propos des capacités réelles de
l'armée russe samsonov se suicida plutôt
que d'affronter le déshonneur d'avoir à
endosser la responsabilité de ce
désastre
[Musique]
la victoire de tannenberg est à
l'origine de la réputation des deux
généraux allemands paul von hindenburg
et erik lund or qui allait jouer un rôle
essentiel au cours de la guerre
à la fin du mois d'août lorsque cette
histoire fut connu l'armée
austro-hongroise lança une offensive
contre les quatre armées russes ce qui
déclencha plusieurs batailles comme
celle de à most komarov ou gagna ne lit
pas sans qu'aucun camp ne parviennent
vraiment à prendre le dessus chacun
restant sur ses positions
le général lee manson sanders fut nommé
commandant suprême de la première armée
turque
les batailles du premier mois de guerre
avaient particulièrement entamé les
troupes du corps expéditionnaire
britannique
le ministre de la guerre anglais lord
kitchener pensait que la guerre durerait
au moins trois années et qu'elle ne
serait certainement pas fini à noël pour
lui il était devenu essentiel de
recruter beaucoup plus de soldats
[Musique]
le gouvernement refusait de prendre en
compte la proposition de kitchener il
décida de jouer sur le patriotisme
populaire qui s'était manifesté dans le
pays au moment du déclenchement des
hostilités
très vite il réussit à réunir cent mille
volontaires grâce un des plus célèbres
slogans de l'histoire votre roi et votre
pays a besoin de vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les hommes se précipitèrent en masse
dans les bureaux de recrutement et grâce
à ce succès kitchener fut autorisé à
relever la limite alors fixé à 100 mille
hommes à la fin 2009 114 plus de cinq
cent mille hommes avaient répondu à son
appel
les nouvelles recrues formèrent de
nouveaux bataillons
[Musique]
à la fin de la guerre certains régiments
britannique avait plus de 40 bataillant
souvent constitué d'hommes qui
partageaient des liens ou qui venait dé
même ville ou village
on les connaissait sous le nom de paul
ce bataillon bien que cette décision de
regrouper ses hommes et joue un rôle
important dans l'esprit de corps de ses
troupes les lourdes pertes les serres
certaines localités totalement 100
hommes
[Musique]
les principaux problèmes de la nouvelle
armée de kitchener et l équipement les
vêtements et l'entraînement la plupart
des officiers avaient été envoyés en
france si bien que l'aide des vétérans
et est accepté avec enthousiasme
même si leurs connaissances étaient
dépassées
[Musique]
d'autres officiers provenaient des corps
de formation de certaines écoles privées
il était affecté à des fonctions
provisoire et on les connaissait sous le
nom dérégulant mais plus souvent sous le
sobriquet des chevaliers provisoire
l'approvisionnement en fusil était trop
lent et souvent lors des premières
séances d'exercice ils durent utilisé
des bâtons en bois
en france les troupes expéditionnaire
était confrontée à une nouvelle sorte de
guerre
les lignes parallèles de trancher avec
leurs lignes de communication et les
défenses en barbelé transformer une
partie du paysage français en s'étendant
de la frontière suisse jusqu'à la mer du
nord en belgique en un front continue
sur 750 km
e
chaque camp tente est occasionnellement
de se lancer dans un raid contre les
lignes adverses pour les briser
transformant le conflit en guerre
d'usure
les soldats devaient prendre position
sur les pentes arrière des collines kars
creuser des tranchées sur les faces
avant en faisait des cibles faciles pour
les artilleurs ennemis
au début de l'automne 1914 le conflit
sur le front ouest semble à s'agiter un
peu
chaque armée selon ça dans une série de
manoeuvres pour tenter de passer par le
nord et d'affaiblir l'ennemi
ces mouvements de 20 la course à la mer
elle finit en impasse les forces
britanniques finir par s'immobiliser
dans la vieille cité belge d'ypres un
mot imprononçable pour les soldats
anglais qui parlait plutôt de whipper
[Musique]
ce nom allait devenir un mot de plus
pour parler de morts et de destructions
car l'une des pires bataille de tout le
front ouest allait s'y dérouler
le terrain tout autour était plat est
détrempée en raison du climat humide il
était impossible de drainer les
tranchées ou de les creuser un peu plus
profond sans qu'elle ne se remplissent
d'eau les terres les plus hautes avait
été prise par les allemands laissant les
positions britanniques s'y exposer aux
tirs ennemis qui lui redressé des écrans
de toile pour masquer les mouvements des
troupes
[Musique]
les allemands décidèrent de faire une
percée à ypres dans le secteur des
britanniques
[Musique]
ces derniers savaient qu'il n'y avait
aucune troupe de réserve derrière eux ce
qui signifiait que si les allemands
parvenait à percer leur ligne ils
pouvaient s'emparer des ports de la
manche ce qui empêcherait le
débarquement de nouveaux soldats et de
tout l'approvisionnement en provenance
de grande bretagne
[Musique]
au début de ce qui allait devenir la
bataille d'ypres le premier corps
britanniques du général soeur douglas
haig réussi à stopper les allemands
depuis leurs positions autour de la
ville
[Musique]
mais leur contre attaque sans lizin et
tourna à la déroute lorsque des fortes
pluies des trompèrent les terres basses
des flandres en un véritable marécage
rempli de milliers de corps de soldats
des deux camps
[Musique]
les quatrième et sixième armée allemande
postés autour d'ypres fut renforcée par
de nombreux soldats dans l'objectif de
parvenir à avancer jusqu'aux ports de
calais et boulogne
[Musique]
des soldats et des pièces d'artillerie
supplémentaires furent engagés lors de
la nouvelle offensive allemande à la fin
du mois d'octobre 1914
mais la résistance des français et des
britanniques fut féroce
[Musique]
plusieurs offensives allemandes
successives échouèrent jusqu'à ce que
les premières neiges n'arrive au milieu
du mois de novembre et mettre un terme à
la première bataille d'ypres
le kaiser avait donné l'ordre à ses
troupes d'écraser la méprisable et
démodé armée du général french depuis
lors être méprisable et démodé est une
marque ironique de respect
[Musique]
tout comme les français les anglais les
allemands avaient été portés par un
enthousiasme patriotique au
déclenchement des hostilités les
universités d'outre-rhin était déserté
et des milliers de jeunes idéalistes
s'était porté volontaire pour une guerre
qui devait le pense et il répare et bien
des erreurs
des milliers d'entre eux moururent à
ypres abattu par les fusils britannique
alors qu'il marchait en rangs serrés
comme à la parade
on
le massacre des enfants fit les gros
titres de la presse germanique
les deux camps épuisé et frustrés par
leurs tentatives de percées s'arrêtèrent
pour panser leurs plaies
certains soldats eurent droit à quelques
jours de permission vasile et est
désormais évident que la guerre ne
serait pas terminée à noël en 1914
l'armée autrichienne attaque à trois
fois la serbie elle fut repoussé les
trois fois
au début du mois de novembre la base
allemand de tsingtao en chine seront
dites aux japonais
dès le début de la guerre l'amiral
maximilien von suppé s'était vu confier
le commandement des navires allemands en
asie
[Musique]
sa mission était d'attaquer les navires
commerciaux naviguant dans l'hémisphère
sud
la flotte de spie comprenait les
croiseurs blindés chambre horst et
daytona ou ainsi que trois croiseurs
légers tous flambant neuf et rapide
[Musique]
le 1er novembre à coronel au large de la
côte chilienne où il se rendait pour
s'approvisionner en charbon ils
engagèrent la flotte britannique sous le
commandement de l'amiral soeur
christopher crédoc
les anglais subir une sévère défaite
[Musique]
plusieurs navires et leurs équipages
furent perdues tout comme leur admiral
[Musique]
les transmissions radio interceptées par
les britanniques montrer que je suis
préparé de nouvelles attaques entre les
navire marchand naviguant dans
l'atlantique afin de couper les lignes
d'approvisionnement de la grande
bretagne
[Musique]
le haut commandement britannique envoya
promptement une flotte sous la
responsabilité du vice-amiral soeur
frédérique sturdy vers l'atlantique sud
afin de stopper les navires allemands
les croiseurs de bataille invincible et
inflexible ainsi que six autres
croiseurs légers constituait cette unité
[Musique]
le plan de ce pic comprenait la
destruction des réserves de charbon et
des installations radios de port stanley
aux malouines
[Musique]
les navires britanniques arrivèrent les
premiers est latent dire lorsque je puis
constate à l'importance du détachement
de la royal navy
il ordonna à ses navires de faire demi
tour et il fut pris en chasse par
l'inflexible et l'invincible les navires
duster lits étaient plus rapides et plus
manoeuvrable si bien que les allemands
se retrouvèrent vite dans une situation
désespérée sous les tirs anglais qui
envoyèrent finalement par le font tous
les vaisseaux du kaiser à l'exception du
dresde est m
[Musique]
dix marins britanniques furent cuvée
dans ce combat mais aucun de leurs
navires ne fut sérieusement endommagé
2200 marin allemand disparu ou se
noyèrent au cours de cet affrontement
ce fut une revanche total
pendant ce temps en france les alliés
dresser les plans de leur première
offensive depuis le début de la guerre
des tranchées débuter au cours de
l'automne les positions étaient plus ou
moins solidement tenue mais le maréchal
joffre chef suprême des armées
françaises avaient la volonté de mettre
un terme rapide au conflit
l'offensive devaient être lancés tout au
long de la ligne des tranchées qui
courait de nieuport en belgique jusqu'à
verdun en passant par les régions de
l'artois et de la champagne
[Musique]
cette offensive divers avec comme cible
le coeur des zones allemande en france
et d'autres petites zones vers le sud
vers saint mihiel
[Musique]
le plan de l'offre était de frapper fort
les allemands en les surclassant du nord
au sud
[Rires]
la taxe suivante par les ardennes
pourrait alors couper leur retraite
[Musique]
une série d'assauts de petite ampleur
commença le 10 décembre
ils furent suivi d' attaque massive à
partir du 20 mai en sous-nombre ou pas
les allemands étaient bien installés
dans leurs tranchées
une fois de plus ils firent la
démonstration de la supériorité des
positions défensives contre les
capacités offensives des troupes alliées
le commandement franco anglais étaient
persuadés que la puissance de
l'infanterie allait l'emporter
les espérait surtout que les offensives
contre les russes sur le front est à les
forcer l'état major allemand a retiré
des bataillons du front ouest
mais en fait les attaques des soldats
contre les positions allemandes défendue
par de nombreuses mitrailleuses se
soldèrent systématiquement par des
échecs
[Musique]
vers mi novembre la 9e armée du général
mac and then écrasa la première armée
russe du général trân quang et en cercle
à la deuxième dans la ville de loos
[Musique]
les russes furent néanmoins lancé une
contre attaque isolant les armées
allemandes du général von scheffer en
retour après neuf jours de combats les
allemands réussir à briser le siège et
firent vingt mille prisonniers ils
prirent aussi leurs pièces d'artillerie
et anéantir le plan russe qui prévoyait
de s'emparer de la silésie régions
allemandes très industrialisée le 29
décembre le général vorontsov fut en
mesure de stopper l'avancée les turcs
dans le caucase au cours de la bataille
de sarry la miche
mais le front reste a ouvert noël
approchait et les pensées des soldats au
fond des tranchées dans les deux camps
aller vers leur foyer
[Musique]
l'optimisme du mois d'août quand tout le
monde pensait que la guerre serait
courte laisser la place à la certitude
que ce serait plus long que prévu
[Musique]
la question du sens de cette guerre
impitoyable se posait à tous
le jour de noël des soldats des deux
camps quittèrent leurs tranchées et se
rencontrèrent au milieu du no man's land
pour partager quelques cigarettes et
échanger leurs voeux
[Musique]
ce n'était pas nouveau au cours de
l'histoire les soldats l'ont toujours
fait mais en ce noël 1914
ce fut particulièrement poignant si on
songe à l'âpreté des combats qui les
avait opposés auparavant les officiers
de haut rang tentèrent de mettre un
terme à ces fraternisation mais le
miracle de noël durera toute la journée
pour certaines sections
certains allaient même jusqu'à planter
des arbres de noël autour des lignes de
trancher
[Musique]
une fois la fête célébrée les troupes
reprirent leur position avec l'espoir
d'être revenu à la maison pour le
prochain noël
[Musique]
e
on
oh